Hello there.
We're just stood here in
lovely downtown Austin for RTX.
Yeah, nice.
It's quite warm, so nice guys like we are,
we're chucking water
balloons at people to--
Very thoughtful.
--keep 'em cool.
Look, there's Freddy W.
Holy crap.
Do you wanna?
Yeah.
I ain't scared.
Ooh!
Hey!
It's my good sandals.
What the heck, man?
Freddie W., what does that stand for?
Freddy wet?
Oh.
Hey.
Cheeky is what you are.
It's going down.
Why are you so alone, Freddy?
What is, why are you guys
called the slow mo guys?
Is it because you guys are slow
and you last really long in bed?
Oh yeah.
Here we go.
I'm you guys.
Oh, I'm just drinking tea.
Let's shoot things in slow motion,
that'll do well on YouTube.
We do do that.
I do say that, as well.
You did, you did say that.
I'm upset now.
That's it.
Hold on.
You guys want a water balloon fight?
I'll give you a water balloon war.
Wow, they're going really quickly?
I'm gonna need a towel.
Three, two, one.
Bullocks.
a big round of applause.
We did not win that.
No, we lost.
We were vastly outnumbered.
I know, right?
I am piss-wrapped,
absolutely piss-wrapped.
I can't believe it.
Special thanks to everyone from RTX
who came and helped us made the video.
And Freddie W.
It was mental, never
seen anything like it.
Never thought I could get
injured by water balloons.
First the junk and the ear hole.
Well, I hope you enjoyed it.
Be sure to follow us on
Twitter and we'll see you
in the next video.
At least I've cooled down now.
I'm gonna go and shower.
Yeah.
Yep.
Maybe we should use that one instead.